okay a few more one d4 again
remove knight f3 again
now let's promote knight c street this
time
maybe there will be no games i'll get
away
which is d4963
no i will not
a4
all right sorry for this yeah let's play
f4 maybe
[Music]
and then knight of three nines
probably going wrong away
at f3 bishop d3 e5
h4 bishop takes h7 and checkmate
actually let's try to sort to win by
removing
e5 so remove f takes and i'm also ready
to play h4
okay if he plays knight somewhere i just
go h4 now i remove bishop takes h7
yeah then i promote knight g5
then i promote h6
and otherwise i go queen h5 and
premovage takes
and this is how we win
okay so now it's important i guess i
remove queen each shade and then i
promote g6 right
yeah i mean i could win by
force but yeah i wanted to be promoting
here and photo
yeah now it's just i mean it's different
story
why is still winning after c5 but um
yeah i must admit like i failed the
main task
should probably remove like d e
to be ready to meet this uh
yeah whatever anyway
yeah queen takes e7 or i don't know
knight takes b7
then we take a 7 go r7
go 96
or maybe we don't go 96 actually we go
d5
and then we keep uh 96 for for
premoving it yeah now i'm pretty much 96
and wait for a move yeah and then i
remove dtakes and
then i i don't know okay now we're
winning here
should i promote e7 it's kind of free
skin
although not that much
yeah he resigns alright thanks for the
game